most of week one has been announced the
cbs schedule as mentioned earlier
steelers at bills oh well pittsburgh
kevin colbert told me last week the gm
of the steelers he always looks at week
one he may not want to look at this week
one because that's going to be a tough
one for pittsburgh jets and panthers a
little sam darnold revenge wow right out
of the gates man i like that yeah i like
that they could have helped that one a
little bit longer i like that one
cardinals at titans that's one of the
17th games that's that's one of the
games that landed on the schedule when
we went to 17. cardinals titans wouldn't
have been played with only 16 games
jaguars at the texans the trevor
lawrence debut against god knows who at
quarterback and then the chargers of the
washington football team all the one
o'clock games on cbs five of them wait
one two three four five of them yes five
of them all at once yeah i mean hey good
slate there i mean seriously under under
the radar chargers washington football
game there at one o'clock chargers got
to start off and then like that west
coast team being at 10 a.m eastern the
darnold bowl
i mean that's that's that is a fast
you're right like a fascinating week one
match up there you know that zach wilson
the new jets quarterback is gonna have
to go down
and play the old jets quarterback uh but
my eye especially out of those one
o'clock games like
my like the steelers bills that can go
either way right i mean you know it's
like
if you're the steelers you're like man
we got to play that group and josh allen
and everything he does geez but also i
could tell you as a quarterback you hate
to play defenses like the steelers early
on in the year too because everything in
training camp is like real simple right
and even pre-season teams aren't really
exotic with their defenses and then you
get into like a week one and all of a
sudden it's like whoa it's blitzberg and
they got seven guys acting like they're
gonna blitz here and they dropped out
and three guys blissed over there and
that could be like a little bit of a
you know
punch in the gut as far as just waking
you up when you have to deal with that
in week one um so that that'll that'll
be something i'll have my eye on in
those one o'clock games
those two teams played in buffalo in
december 26 15 was the score the bills
won but you know the the point is this
you have four months to get ready for
week one that's right that can be your
obsession and some teams make it their
obsession they do they spend the
entirety of the time getting ready for
that first game and they worry about
week two when week two comes uh the fox
games there are four well we didn't talk
about the fortune yeah let's talk about
it
there's a major cbs 425 game a playoff
rematch right out of the gates the
cleveland browns the browns are not the
browns anymore but they play the chiefs
so their hopes of getting off to a
one-and-oh start are well look it's not
impossible it can happen but i'm sure
they would have rather played someone
else to start the season brown's at the
chiefs with the secondary game on cbs of
the dolphins at the patriots yeah no i
mean first off yeah baker vs mahomes
that's awesome divisional playoff game
this is a game mahomes got knocked out
in against cleveland so there's that
angle you can play again you play on
cleveland maybe could have won the game
if it weren't for the fumble into the
end zone north korea rule that i love in
his awesome rule yes best rule there is
ever invented and but but like yeah this
is gonna mean cleveland
you never wanna play mahomes but man
cleveland's gotta have a belief of going
like wait we've improved our team we
believe in ourselves because of what we
did you know at the end of last year and
everything like that
and i do think there's a little bit of
like you ended the season against this
team okay we got a feel for them and
what they did to us in the playoffs and
all those things to where they shouldn't
be too scared going into kansas city to
play them
and and they've got four months to get
ready for it that's the game that the
browns are gonna be focused on until
week one rules around uh let's flip it
over to the fox schedule
they've got four one o'clock games that
means there's going to be nine games
it's one of the things i don't like that
wait we wait all that time for the
season to start and then you have nine
games that all begin at the same time
49ers at the lions very intriguing the
knee biting
uh regime begins with a tough test
against the 49ers also it's a renewal of
the old jim harbaugh jim schwartz moment
from 10 years ago i don't think i don't
think kyle shanahan and dan campbell are
going to have quite a moment like that
after the game but we can always hope
for it seattle at indianapolis a sneaky
great game yes out of the gates you know
when you look for games that stand out
at one o'clock i think it's steelers
bills and seahawks cults i agreed i mean
you got the zimmer bowl with the vikings
and the bengals that should be that
would be cool but yes i mean that fox
schedule my eyes are all over seattle at
indianapolis i mean indianapolis is is a
super bowl contender and we know seattle
is right there on the edge of that too
uh so yeah that's that's the one that i
think pops to me more than anything the
san francisco one i'm interested mike
just to see of course if it will be a
trey lance or you know who's gonna be
starting quarterback but you know i
think to your point the the seahawks
colts game is the one that really takes
the cake
and then as we mentioned earlier in the
program the 4 25 p.m eastern games on
fox and both networks have 4 25 p.m
eastern yeah what's up with that it's
one of the other right week 17 is the
only week that i was aware of in the
past the final week of the season where
they clustered the games at 425 on both
networks i i need to look into this why
maybe i missed this when they did the
new deals i don't know why both cbs and
fox have 4 25 p.m eastern games at the
same time be that as it may
packers saints
as the main game on fox
and then it's broncos giants which
becomes the main game
on fox
if aaron rodgers broncos the ultimate
hedge for week one i wonder how many
times we'll see that i wonder if every
425 packers game is going to be
accompanied by a 425 denver game all
year long chris yeah it might we might
you're right yeah that that that seems
that makes sense when you put it put it
that way
i mean hey the packers saints game with
or without rogers is going to have major
nfc implications but of course it's
going to be a lot better if rogers is
there and yeah we got the saints angle
of like their quarterback situation and
the saints are still a really good
football team but did have some turnover
this offseason did lose some players and
all that you know and then the the
giants denver game is
yes two teams trying to find their way
make their mark back in their respective
conferences and everything like that but
man
if aaron rodgers was there for that game
back in new york to start off the year
and everything like that that stadium
will be electric
also the monday night football game for
week one
will be the ravens
at the raiders
this is the first year since 2006 there
is not a monday night double header espn
replaced that with a saturday double
header in the final week of the season
with games that will have playoff
implications
so
the the doubleheader to begin the season
staying up until
1am or later that's over that was that's
the put that's finito that was a hell of
a way to end that first week and i would
typically watch the first half of the
late game and then speed through the
second half before the show because it's
just too much it's too much yeah so uh
it's no more it's now raven's raiders to
cap the wick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports